un nouveau clerfontaine pour les Bleus à
2 mois du début de l'Euro 2016 un
bâtiment de 5200 m Carr été inauguré ce
vendredi 8 avril en présence du
secrétaire d'État chargé des sports
Thierry breayard et du président de la
Fédération Française de Football Noël
ograet la structure abritera notamment
le centre de formation et de conférence
en parallèle les terrains les espaces de
musculation et le centre médical ont été
modernisés pour l'urau pour les joueurs
ceux qui viennent s'entraîner il faut
qu'ils aient une qualité de terrain
aussi bonne que dans les grands clubs
c'est des joueurs de ha niveau donc
aujourd'hui l'effort a été fait sur tous
les terrains ils ont un gazon NAF
exceptionnel qualitatif donc ça c'est
important ensite au niveau médical on
est bien équipé au niveau technique au
niveau récupération on est parfaitement
équipé je pense qu'on est au niveau de
satisfaction pour des joueurs de ha
niveau pour rénover ce site de 56
hectares ouvert depuis 1988 6 millions
d'euros ont été investis sur 3 ans les
joueurs de l'équipe de France ont glissé
des idées pour améliorer les équipements
il y a des des échanges bien évidemment
par rapport aux besoins qu'ils peuvent
avoir et après c'est en discussion aussi
avec avec mon staff staff technique et
staff médical et après évidemment c'est
toujours validé par par la Fédération
par rapport au coût des travaux mais on
a toujours eu des des personnes à
l'écoute pour nous faire en sorte de
nous mettre dans les meilleures
conditions l'eurot débutera en France ce
10 juin prochain les tricolurs devrai
s'installer dans leur camp de base à
partir du 5 juin